I think everybody knows the game
rock-paper-scissors paper covers rock
rock breaks scissors scissors got paper
we all learned to play this and what you
want to do is be unpredictable to your
opponent what's the best strategy well
if you just don't want to lose your best
strategy is to play randomly because
then there's no pattern in your moves so
there's nothing to track it's very hard
for human beings to to to play randomly
to do anything randomly there we're not
good at creating random series and it's
been studied it carefully for instance
if you were obliged to probably
rock-paper-scissors for big bucks and
you wanted to break even
here's the strategy you might well adopt
go to a table of random numbers and copy
down few hundred and trade the numbers
in for RP and s rock-paper-scissors and
memorize the list or keep the list in a
secure place and then play according to
that list that should pretty well
guarantee that your that your moves will
have no pattern that will be detectable
by your opponent as long as he can't see
your list it's very important that you
have to keep it secret otherwise of
course you're sitting duck now I think
that simple example exposes one of the
seeds of the freewill literature people
sense in their bones and they don't
quite know why that it's very important
that their moves not be predictable in
life they want a certain amount of
unpredictability they don't want to be
too predictable there's a very good
reason for this there's a good game
theoretic reason why they ought to want
to preserve a certain amount of
unpredictability because if you're too
predictable especially if you're sort of
hyper rational and you're always doing
making the best move all things
considered if somebody else can figure
out what those best moves are then they
take you for a ride now I think here's
what's happened people have recognized
for thousands of years that an
autonomous agent needs to preserve a
certain amount of unpredictability in
order to maintain autonomy and they've
figured as philosophers and others often
do well if unpredictability is good
perfect unpredictability is better and
so they've decided that they ought to be
perfectly unpredictable they ought they
ought to be there their choices ought to
be purely undetermined a quantum on
determined so that as Jerry Fodor once
said even God couldn't tell whether Eve
would need the Apple or not well if you
have to worry about God if you're
playing rock paper and scissors with God
then you should want quantum
indeterminacy because then even God
can't read your list but for ordinary
mortals for the sorts of antagonists and
interlocutors that we're apt to
encounter in our lives we don't need
perfect unpredictability we just need
good enough for government work
unpredictability and we can have that
without indeterminacy altogether in
other words there's no reason to hold
out hope for in determinism it is not a
threat to free will in the important
moral sense you can have all the free
will you could ever reasonably want
without in determinism
you